disait en titre la guerre se rapprochent
d'odessa le port de la mer noire est
l'un des objectifs de poutine et pour la
première fois les russes auraient
bombardé des faubourgs de la ville
informations données par les autorités
ukrainiennes locale d'après elle des
immeubles d'habitations ont été touchées
mais il n'y aurait pas de victime julie
dungl of bon jour on vous retrouve en
direct de micola yves c'est la dernière
grande ville avant odessa et vous avez
aussi assisté à d'importants
bombardements ce lundi
oui depuis ce matin ça n'arrête pas on
entend des bombardements aériens et ici
je me trouve dans le centre-ville de
nicolay est fait vous le voir voyez sur
les images de mares à l'edml alameda oui
cet immeuble a été bombardée par un raid
aérien aux alentours de 1h heure locale
ce qui signifie midi heure de paris il
s'agit d'un hôtel au rez-de-chaussée il
y avait une banque selon les personnes
avec lesquelles on a pu parler bien
aucune victime ne serait à déplorer on a
également entendu d'importants raids
aériens en banlieue de la ville nous
avons tenté de nous rendre pour voir ce
qui s'y passe est malheureusement les
checkpoints nous on nous empêcher on a
pu entendre également bien sûr ces
sirènes que les habitants de nicolas
yves connaître si bien depuis les débuts
de la guerre et des gens se
précipitaient pour se mettre à l'abri on
a pu parler également avec des pompiers
de la ville qui nous ont fait référence
aux derniers bombardements très
important avec énormément de victimes
notamment vendredi sur une caserne
militaire où plus de 50 soldats sont
morts et de nombreux ont été blessés on
sent beaucoup de fatigue beaucoup de
découragement chez les habitants de la
ville ces pompiers me disaient qu'ils
avaient l'impression de vivre un enfer
et qu'il n'aurait jamais eu l'impression
de pouvoir vivre quelque chose de tel de
telle sorte au 21ème siècle donc
beaucoup de lassitude beaucoup
d'inquiétude aussi hein parce que ce que
nous disent les gens ici est bien c'est
que ces bombardements ont l'air de
s'intensifier et puis nous étions à
odessa durant la nuit et au petit matin
nous avons pu également entendre des
bombardements aériens sans pour autant
pour l'instant avoir pu nous rendre sur
place merci pour ce compte-rendu
juridique de l'ofs avec amara la
médaille oui derrière la caméra envoyés
spéciaux à micola yves com